but first we're going to begin with
breaking news that comes from Southern
California a dangerous wildfire exploded
overnight burning dozens of homes and
prompting mandatory evacuations high
winds driving the flames are expected to
last for hours the fire started last
night in Sylmar northwest of downtown
Los Angeles fueled by dry conditions and
wind gusts up to 70 miles an hour it's
now burned more than four thousand acres
it's one of eight active wildfires
burning in California days after power
was shut off the hundreds of thousands
of people in an effort to prevent fires
Errol Barnett is in Porter Ranch Errol
what's the situation there right now
now this wildfire really exploded in
power in just the last few minutes you
can also see the winds and how they fuel
the fires strength but there's another
component as well and those are the
embers the fire is carrying these embers
allowing this wildfire to jump across
the street those embers landing on these
homes
that's why firefighters are taking
defensive positions to try and protect
this property but there's only so much
they can do Wildfire flames jumping to
major freeways destroying homes and
burning vehicles giving people living
nearby little time to pack up and leave
you have to keep in mind as you watch
this that we are witnessing one person
or one family's absolute worst nightmare
their home up in flames in a matter of
hours I don't feel like leaving my
knowing what's gonna happen workers at a
Wildlife Center say horses that got
loose were corralled and brought safely
inside spot fires are widespread
covering hundreds of acres to the
southeast the via Calimesa mobile home
park burned into the night the fire
began when a trash truck dumped burning
garbage into dry grass firefighters
working to contain the flames more than
six hours after they began thus erratic
winds blew Amber's into more and more
structures 74 were destroyed some people
shoveled dirt onto hot spots and pulled
out their own hoses to try and stop the
fire from spreading I'm just glad that
we made it out people escaping the
flames say the fire spreads so quickly
many had to leave their pets behind I
just ran into my neighbor right here and
she's holding her dog and she's missing
- earlier Thursday a fire in Fontana
east of Los Angeles damaged two homes
it's unclear where the power was cut in
this area more than 800,000 California
customers had their electricity turned
off over the past three days to reduce
the fire risk California's governor
blasting the state's utilities for not
modernizing their grids
it's decisions that were not made that
have led to this moment they desire to
advance not public safety but profits
this area is under a mandatory
evacuation and we're watching as
residents pack up their possessions and
leave now the state's largest utility
that specific Gaston electric says they
got no choice but to turn off the power
because of the dry conditions and high
winds
they will restore power once these winds
die down
and after they've inspected some 25,000
miles the power line
Anthony Errol Barnett with those
frightening lis fast-moving fire
wildfires in California thanks